- [Voiceover] This is the red-kneed tarantula.
She's got quite the outfit.
Unfortunately, her striking features
have made her a hot commodity
in the illegal pet trade.
Found in the forests
of southwestern Mexico,
red-kneeds are some of
the largest spiders,
growing up to eight inches in size.
Besides size,
their beautiful red, white,
black and orange hairs
are what separates them
from other spiders.
The hairs on their legs are
used to sense vibrations
from predators and prey.
They prey on large
insects, frogs and mice,
biting and injecting
them with their venom.
Their alluring look has made them
the most popular captive tarantula,
causing a major population decline.
Today, regulations are in
place requiring permits
to remove any of these
beauties from the wild.
This is the red-kneed tarantula.